un cortejo de una decena de kilómetros
epicentro de la resistencia campesina
centenares de carpas tractores y
camiones ocupan esta porción de
autopista que conduce a nueva delhi
[Música]
desde hace diez meses estos agricultores
acampan en las puertas de la capital
india entre ellos harpreet singh 22 años
larga vida a los granjeros
todos los granjeros que llegaron juntos
desde pensaba caminan hacia la escena
principal para mostrar su presencia
variar hasta ver yo aprendí berninger
tal como cientos de miles de otros
granjeros harpreet a reclama el retiro
de una reforma votada hace un año por el
parlamento indio tres leyes que
pretenden liberalizar la agricultura y
abrirla a las empresas privadas hijo de
campesino vive aquí desde el mes de
diciembre ni el frío y la polución de
ayer ni el calor y la monzón del verano
han afectado su determinación
así los manifestantes vienen en grupos
buses vienen desde ponia una vez a la
semana un grupo llega a permanecer aquí
unos 15 días luego se va y es
reemplazado por otro grupo hacemos esas
rotaciones porque ellos nos permiten
seguir protestando ocupándonos de
nuestras tierras y nuestros hogares en
los campamentos alrededor de nueva delhi
la cantidad de manifestantes ha
disminuido poco a poco pero la
movilización no ha parado ha
evolucionado y ha llegado a las zonas
rurales a un centenar de kilómetros de
la capital india se encuentra el pueblo
de patrick en el estado rural de haryana
and under malik es agricultor tal como
su padre y su abuelo en el pasado de
regreso de la zona de protesta viene a
verificar sus tierras cinco hectáreas de
arroz y caña de azúcar una exceso de
agua debe reducir el nivel de lo
contrario mis cosechas serán anegadas
llovió mucho en esta monzón hasta ahora
el arroz cultivado en india solo es
vendido en mercados locales a un precio
mínimo garantizado
establecido por el estado cualquiera que
sea el rendimiento lo necesario para
garantizar la supervivencia de
campesinos como annan pero la nuevas
leyes pueden ponerle fin a este sistema
proteccionista los agricultores podrán
vender directamente sus cosechas a los
grandes grupos de la industria
agroalimentaria el miedo de los
granjeros que las empresas privadas
pongan sus condiciones sin negociación
si firmamos un contrato con estas
empresas y nuestras cosechas no son
suficientemente buenas para ellos si
tienen manchas por ejemplo pues con ese
contrato las empresas pueden negarse a
comprarlos la piel se quedará con
nuestros inventarios la aplicación de
esta reforma fue temporalmente
suspendida por la corte suprema una
medida insuficiente para los campesinos
entonces para mantener la presión sobre
el primer ministro narendra modi
manifestaciones inmensas como ésta
tienen lugar regularmente en estados
rurales del país
los granjeros se alistan para participar
en una gran manifestación en
muzaffargarh desde las 11 horas así es
la estrategia adoptada por los
representantes de los trajeron extender
la protesta a los pueblos frente al
impasse en las negociaciones rabbit asad
es miembro del sindicato de los
granjeros wind es el más importante del
país desde varias semanas hace visitas
puerta a puerta para convencer a los
pueblos de que se unan al llamado a la
huelga general prevista para el primer
aniversario de la portación de las leyes
ahora a poner a su marido
vengan con sus hijas sus madres sus
abuelas y sus días
sí claro
llamado a la movilización y a la unidad
pero no solamente los sindicatos
pretende empezar en las próximas
elecciones claves de ovnis incitando a
la población a no votar por el pj para
el partido del primer ministro
no es una cuestión de región de religión
o de casta es el momento para la india
de deshacerse del viejo tape para ello
contamos con una vacuna las elecciones
regionales del 2022 en uttar pradesh yo
y si ello no es suficiente una segunda
dosis las elecciones generales en el
2024 contra el gobierno de modi en day
si fuese un verdadero gobierno ya nos
habría escuchado por la india ya no
tiene gobierno la hiniesta dirigida por
las grandes empresas seguiremos luchando
hasta nuestro último aliento no le
tememos a la muerte pase lo que pase no
nos soltaremos hasta que no hayamos
ganado la lucha
pasando el umbral de los diez meses este
levantamiento campesino es el más largo
que haya conocido la india desde su
independencia